AFS passes the first test. It does address
the issue of mutual suspicion from fellow users, as
well as from the server. Unfortunately, AFS fails the
second test and that is protecting the user from
the system. There's no way to protect the
user from the system because the user has to
trust the system. Everything is stored on the system,
so in that sense there is no protection for
the user from the system itself. It also fails on the third attribute,
confinement of resource usage. For instance, a given user can make a lot of
calls on the server. In other words, they could consume a lot of network
bandwidth. There's no way to confine resource
usage in the Andrew File System. And
this can also be the basis for Denial Of Service attacks. If one malicious user
or an errant program that is running on
the virtual workstation starts generating a whole bunch
of network packets, genuine network packets, directed at
the server, it can inundate the network and
prevent others from getting useful work done. So,
in other words, confinement of resource usage is
not something that exists in the AFS
system. It passes the authentication test. We can
validate in both directions, the client and the server, so the answer is yes on
that one. The last attribute is the
integrity of the server, remember that in the
Andrew system the assumption is that the clients
running on the virtual work station, they communicate
to vice using insecure links. On the other hand, the servers themselves
are inside, in some sense, a firewall and therefore they don't need any
secure communication. So their links that are inside the server network is
assumed to be secure and therefore
there is no authentication or encryption inside
the server network. Therefore, if somebody were to somehow get into that
firewall they can create havoc. So the only way you can give server integrity in
the Andrew File System is by physically enforcing who can get into those
walls of the server. So physical and social mores are the only way to secure
the integrity of the servers themselves. So I'm going to
give it not a passing mark on server integrity, because by
design, the servers are assumed to be in a secure environment
and that can be one of the biggest sources of vulnerabilities.